[Music]  you're traveling you have new music I  got to know everyone at ET we love your  Instagram your bed series how do you get  that perfect photo for the best well a  really good friend is the first step  we're going to actually take the best  series to the next level we're going to  do a real fun shoot for coming up soon  so we're going to hire a professional  photographer  and you had such a successful run on  scream queens I want to know what life  is like after that would you work on  another project with Ryan Murphy I of  course but I'm really excited I'm going  to be on a new show and ABC starting in  the fall it's called the mayor and I  love my boys on the show I'm so excited  to work with girls for the past couple  of years so but I love my screen prints  and I obviously love Ryan Murphy so I  will come back whenever he will have me  [Music]